[Music]
here are two images of a house there is
one obvious difference but to this
patient
PS they looked completely identical PS
had suffered a stroke that damaged the
right side of her brain leaving her
unaware of everything on her left side
but though she could discern no
difference between the houses when
researchers asked her which she would
prefer to live in she chose the house
that wasn't burning not once but again
and again PS is brain was still
processing information from her whole
field of vision she could see both
images and tell the difference between
them she just didn't know it if someone
threw a ball at her left side she might
duck but she wouldn't have any awareness
of the ball or any idea why she ducked
PS is condition known as Hemi spatial
neglect reveals an important distinction
between the brains processing of
information and our experience of that
processing that experience is what we
call consciousness we are conscious of
both the external world and our internal
selves we are aware of an image in much
the same way we are aware of ourselves
looking at an image or our inner
thoughts and emotions but where does
consciousness come from scientists
theologians and philosophers have been
trying to get to the bottom of this
question for centuries without reaching
any consensus one recent theory is that
consciousness is the brains imperfect
picture of its own activity to
understand this theory it helps to have
a clearer idea of one important way the
brain processes information from our
senses based on sensory input it builds
models which are continuously updating
simplified descriptions of objects and
events in the world everything we know
is based on these models they never
capture every detail of the things they
describe just enough for the brain to
determine appropriate responses
for instance one model built deep into
the visual system codes white light as
brightness without color in reality
white light includes wavelengths that
correspond to all the different colors
we can see our perception of white light
is wrong and oversimplified but good
enough for us to function likewise the
brains model of the physical body keeps
track of the configuration of our limbs
but not of individual cells or even
muscles because that level of
information isn't needed to plan
movement if it didn't have the model
keeping track of the body's size shape
and how it is moving at any moment we
would quickly injure ourselves the brain
also needs models of itself for example
the brain has the ability to pay
attention to specific objects and events
it also controls that focus shifting it
from one thing to another internal and
external according to our needs without
the ability to direct our focus we
wouldn't be able to assess threats
finish a meal or function at all to
control focus effectively the brain has
to construct a model of its own
attention with 86 billion neurons
constantly interacting with each other
there's no way the brains model of its
own information processing can be
perfectly self descriptive but like the
model of the body or our conception of
white light it doesn't have to be our
certainty that we have a metaphysical
subjective experience may come from one
of the brains models a cut corner
description of what it means to process
information in a focused and deep manner
scientists have already begun trying to
figure out how the brain creates that
self model MRI studies are a promising
Avenue for pinpointing the networks
involved these studies compare patterns
of neural activation when someone is and
isn't conscious of a sensory stimulus
like an image the results show that the
areas needed for visual processing are
activated whether or not the participant
is aware of the image but a whole
additional network lights up only when
they are conscious of seeing the image
patients with hemispatial neglect like
PS typically have damage to one
particular part of
network more extensive damage to the
network can sometimes lead to a
vegetative state with no sign of
consciousness
evidence like this brings us closer to
understanding how consciousness is built
into the brain but there's still much
more to learn for instance the way
neurons in the networks related to
consciousness compute specific pieces of
information is outside the scope of our
current technology as we approach
questions of consciousness with science
we'll open new lines of inquiry into
human identity to continue exploring
life's big questions check out this
playlist
[Music]